see you see you're getting infected by
the chest bug
yeah exactly exactly you know what i
think christian has a very special guest
thank you sharon yes i'm here with a
very happy
winner the first winner of today's round
there is uh the leader in the junior
section
hans niemon hans welcome back to the
studio how
important was for you to bring uh to
come today
and show a great performance after
yesterday well two days ago you made the
draw
with the white pieces that was a
difficult draw in our opinion
how important was it for you to show
your dominance in today's game
very very important especially
this is sort of the wild card and he's
definitely the weakest link in the event
so this is sort of the point that i
really needed to get and i think this
point
will help solidify my lead and i think
i'll have a full point lead going into
the next game
in the last three rounds i have two
whites against
um the lowest opposition i could play so
definitely very very important to
take advantage of this opportunity just
to go back a couple of days ago what was
your strategy going into
that game against john burke um
well i think you guys mentioned this in
the broadcast but when i played a dtx c3
instead of b take c3
objectively beat excuse the best move um
but you know i wanted to get a position
with with no risk
and just play chess i'm in a very
calm way and i wasn't in that much of an
ambitious mood so you know i was okay
with a draw
i i felt it was just important to shut
him down i see it just won two games in
a row so
sort of closing his momentum and
retaining my lead was was the most
important thing
and i and i also felt that in terms of
pairings
if you compare him on in his it's really
just not fair at all because in the
first five games i i played
every single person that's like in the
top five and he has them all now so
yeah that definitely felt like the right
strategy let's go
into today's game and see how do you
feel the opening went
where was the critical moment up to now
it seems
pretty much theory hans
did you feel is this theory are we in
your prep so
you know after my prep ended after
bishop to f4 the the best move after
knight c6
is to play knight takes c5 b takes c5
bishop to e3 knight d4 queen d1 and then
after e5
and now here the computer gives a bit of
an edge
for black but it requires uh
extreme precision to get you know maybe
a 0.3 or 0.4 and if
white isn't accurate the black just gets
long-term slightly better position
um considering the knight on d4 and then
maybe the long-term play on the b
file as well um so this is what i i
wanted to go for and i didn't expect him
to
be precise but clearly he was ready with
bishop four which was certainly
very surprising but the interesting
thing is after
uh so castle's natural rook d1 and this
is what i think happened i think
he expected i think the best move is e5
instead of castles
and then he expected me to play um
bishop h4 h6 and then now bishop
uh sorry bishop f4 e5 bishop g5 h6
bishop before g5 bishop g and then there
i assume that this is correct
but when you you know include rick d1
and castle
it's just almost it's just very bad for
him um
so now yeah now it's fine but after
castles are d1
if i i don't know what happened um
he just he played it very quickly which
which generally made much sense but i
guess
it was really confusing to whether he
was in his preparation or wasn't
as an old pawn grubber question for you
you dismissed this opportunity
uh for a reason and what was that well
if i was playing you i would have
considered it
i would have you know i i spent maybe 30
seconds
contemplating it briefly then i was like
yeah yeah i'm not playing
uh playing badly yeah yeah so i
i i thought okay like rookie eight if
bishop takes c5 of d5
right um so you were willing to go even
worse case i can play like knight d4
uh let's say queen to d1 queen b6
sacking an exchange and i would and i'd
be totally fine like you know or even
even maybe queen takes b2 is a move but
even rook takes that fa
i was okay intuitively this this felt
fine i guess the engine gives a small
edge but i i
i would assume that requires a in
inhuman
you know level of precision um
exactly just a quick that was just uh
my guess work but at this moment so
you felt good so here you know i i did
uh
here paying attention in psychology
class definitely helped me
why you know i had a bit of a read on
them if i could do an instant replay i
could do a little analysis for you know
in basketball
you look through and you watch but i
don't know if you guys have the tech for
that but
there was a moment where um i was
looking
you know at the board and i was trying
to figure out if he was in his
preparation because
g4 this i just went upon right so
intuitively i'm like what's what is it
what is he doing
right but then um i started to look at
him and
he's i noticed his eye movement he's
like moving quickly i'm like why is he
calculating
if he knows all this and then after he
did like a few quick eye movements he um
he looked at me and he made eye contact
for the first time like the entire game
like i kept on just you know staring him
down like i mentioned in my pre
tournament interview
yeah and he just wasn't engaging in a
stare down and i was like okay
and then finally made eye contact and i
felt like that was sort of a
look for confirmation to see if what he
was doing was correct and
that's when i kind of uh my my fear of
being cognizant opening pressure sort of
vaporized
and i was able to to play but yeah
knight d5 g5 this is this is uh
not looking good and you snip the pawn
knight takes e4 and at this point
i mean it just felt like it was all
you i mean there was an avalanche yeah
after this move d3 bishop f5 was
letting the dogs out so to speak you
know i mean the pawn on d4 is no great
shakes i mean
i prefer black's position don't get me
wrong but this move d3 just opened up
this bishop and
did you already at this moment think oh
my goodness
i've got this yeah definitely i felt
very good here and
i think it's also a really great feeling
to know
like to have a lot of the heart like i'm
doing a lot of
intense open preparation and to like see
it sort of
come to fruition it's just a great
feeling um and all in this tournament
most of my games
my preparation or at least my style of
opening maybe this my preparation didn't
really concretely
show in this game but the type of
position that i wanted to get
yeah now yeah bishop yeah you just
every move is just yeah not rick d6 and
you should resign but
yeah it's a hammer blow yeah yeah
i was every move i thought he was going
to resign and then he kept playing
exactly and uh here i thought okay queen
f3 h5 then he's going to resign
right because i was like okay i could
play rook rick h2 take take king g4
queen before king f5 rook f2 win the
queen
right but i was like okay maybe he he
believes
that he can play but h5 i thought was
the the killer but uh yeah
we we do do you do you have a name for
a checkmate with the pawn
do you have a name for it uh yeah um
checkmate with a pawn
i think he car has a name for it really
the lobster pincer no maybe not the
i don't know he car definitely has a
name for it i think
maybe and he hikar would say you know i
pinned him with a juicer and i lobster
pincered him and
you know he couldn't handle it damn that
sounds correct not as good as mine which
is soulmates
because we were thinking of the soul of
chess
yes soulmates sharon came up with pretty
good right
pretty good decent like you know you and
xqc
definitely have a lot in common with
your naming of of chess
we do i i assume you know who exqc is or
yes of course yeah i know so
so uh yeah yeah i'm a good liar as well
um
i have a get to know your question we
saw you at dinner uh yesterday what's
your favorite kind of food
and if you had to choose one meal to
have every single day for a week what
would that be
just i think my i'll just be at home and
have my mother cook for me that's
it honestly good home cooking teriyaki
chicken
with a smoothie and you know i'm living
life
oh amazing delicious one more who's your
favorite chess star and who's your
favorite non-chess
celebrity that you love favorite chess
star yeah outside of yourself
no no i wouldn't want to be labeled
arrogant at all
i'm sure twitter would be riled up but
um
right yeah um i think i i admire
a few people for different reasons but
you know the magnus i think
i i i i do admire but i think it would i
would
have to be bobby fisher okay he's not a
current child
but yeah bobby fischer on more of a uh
i i definitely can relate to and as an
inspiration of mine
and what about non-chess celebrity
that is a tough question um i know the
answer i
wait i'm thinking i think it's someone
uh can it be a someone in a netflix show
yeah raymond reddington is my absolute
hero
which uh blacklist okay so he yeah
raymond writing
he's like he's in blacklist and that
i think he the way he the way he runs
his criminal organization
i would say has inspired the way i think
about chess
interesting yeah okay i like that okay
well hans again congratulations keep up
the good work you're looking good
you are uh and you're my pick by the way
to win so
keep it going yeah you did yesterday to
somebody else
okay thank you thank you